Most people don't even make a resolution
anymore.
Why?
Because they made him from years and
years and years and they know they're
not going to follow through.
So after a while,
who wants to disappoint yourself?
Who wants to be upset with yourself?
Why even bother to set a new standard
for this year?
You know,
it's going to be the same as last year.
Many of us don't act because we want
other people's approval.
We want everybody to like us and to
accept us.
And that's not possible.
Many of us don't do the things that we
want to do and don't act because of lack
of self confidence.
We don't believe enough in ourselves.
There's no denying that inside of you.
The only thing that's gonna make you
happy and,
but you're ahead and the decades ahead,
it's going to be having you have an
experience where on a regular basis you
feel like your life is making progress.
So it's gotta be a vision that's
compelling.
Something that you know it's going to be
a gift to make sure that it happens.
Yeah.
If you want to do anything worthwhile in
life,
you've got to be hungry.
And so I started working to develop
myself.
He said,
I want you to practice everyday being a
disc jockey.
I said,
but I don't have any job now.
He said,
it doesn't matter.
You said that it's better to be prepared
for an opportunity and not have one than
to have an opportunity and not be
prepared.
No excuse that.
If you decided that you want to do this,
if it becomes hot and do it hard,
if it difficult.
So what?
Beginning of the year we have this
tradition,
but it goes beyond tradition.
It's something inside of us that makes
us want to make things better.
And I think part of it is the calendar
gives us this idea that we get to have a
fresh start,
that we get to start from fresh and have
this great victory and it's really,
the calendar itself is quite arbitrary.
It's wonderful to use it,
but if you didn't use it effectively,
let's use the calendar to serve you
today.
Let's just see what does it really take
to make this thing happen?
Because there's no denying that inside
of you.
The only thing that's going to make you
happy,
but you're adding the decades ahead.
It's going to be having you up an
experience where on a regular basis you
feel like your life is making progress.
Just thank you.
What would your life be like if you
decided to keep your commitment?
It is important and the area of
motivating yourself.
It's important to know why you're doing
it,
because that mine will say,
why bother?
Why go through all this?
This is too hard.
No,
throw in the towel.
It's not worth it.
If you make the changes in yourself,
you're going to be proud this year and
no amount of money or accolades from
other people can mirror the feeling of
being proud of knowing you've taken back
control of your life or you've taken a
great life to another level.
Because once you do that,
you have something you can give other
people.
Would it be your kids and your friends
and your family and ultimately that's
why it's about.